[Applaudissements]
quant à la guerre si la photo
vous êtes aussi actuellement sur france
2 avec votre série documentaire sur le
fond dans lequel vous explorez le monde
à la rencontre de personnes qui sont
actives pour défendre la planète et j'ai
eu envie de faire un quiz sur
l'environnement alors oui c'est ça c'est
toi qui vas répond j'ai fait faire alors
je sais un filtre stram gram installant
ce qu'on a pu faire juste pour notre
émission pour l'instant n'existe pas
bien sûr quoique regard des gens qui
vont s'afficher sur mon front et je dois
dire du bien 2 f ça quoi haxhi répond
bien lequel de ces aliments nécessite le
plus d'eau pour sa production doc gynéco
boeuf le café ou le chocolat
je crois que c'est le chocolat qui est
le plus grand malheur donc très bon
[Applaudissements]
vieux bien dans la merde
michel cymes alors michel cymes et moi
je vais dire du bien de michel cymes je
vais vous dire michel cymes c'est un
site c'est un excellent médecin
voilà je suis aussi demain j'étais
malade le premier médecin j'irai voir
après mon père ça michel cymes s'est
juré c'est sûr c'est sûr et certain
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai envie qu'on fasse un petit jeu vous
présenter à et chacun d'entre vous doit
aller faire un câlin à à une personne de
son choix et lui dire pourquoi il est
fait un câlin benjamin ce jeu là dedans
non ce sera non pas parce que c'est le
grand frère
[Applaudissements]
pourrais-je pour fêter ces retrouvailles
de faire un petit smack
alors à toi tu entends par là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je trouvais qu'elle avait reçus
[Applaudissements]
merci mon julien detre les quand je suis
là j'ai l'impression que c'est comme si
tu allais dans ta maison de campagne en
passant s'est pas complètement chez toi
pas ce métier pole mais quand tu viens
tu as tes habitudes
on voulait revenir tout de suite évacué
une image qu'on mettrait s'ouvre
[Musique]
et bien ce soir il y en a quatre et de
faire mieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
asie
[Applaudissements]
alors
[Musique]
ah oui
m
[Musique]
il savait qu'on à l'antenne ou sinon ça
va mon bernard c'est cyril hanouna
savamment vers là je voulais te faire un
gros bisou
je passais gentil peut dire qu on s'est
regardé hier que quand tu as regardé
hier
là j'ai vu là tu avais quitté le plateau
d'europe 1 laier bon c'était encore un
peu chaud j'ai s'est expliqué dans le
foot ce qui peut se passer dans des
émissions comme ça si tu es mené à la mi
temps parce que on a mis deux penaltys a
justifié un trait et qu'après la mi
temps tu viens et que finalement tu
gagne 3,2
d'ailleurs on voit bien qu'elle est un
tueur et bien sûr tu l'aimais parce que
ils sont conscients que tout était fait
pour que tu perds le match et que malgré
tout il gagnera
je t'embrasse à montbernard que j'adore
c'est qui ah oui gilles verdez bah oui
et adore aussi tu vois il est vrai mais
aussi de choses dont on n'a jamais parlé
ces bains avec plaisir je sais comment
je récompense quand un accident qui me
convient je t'aime tu parles de furiani
puisque j étais au drame ne survienne
ça y est elle accepte et je peux vous le
dire aujourd'hui je vais partir non la
semaine prochaine
mais rihanna la mémoire margot robbie
alors il y aura les boiboite du ciné et
dans une boîte
il y aura le voyage à londres avec moi
couvrez-la 2 si vous voulez voilà
maintenant les yeux à les ouvrir à des
vols à 2 allée voilà voilà deux ils
paradaient
[Applaudissements]
le travail non mais c'est quand ils
disent 24 12
chez 24 chambres à la fin d'année
prochaine avant 2019 c'est raté
c'est périmé ah bah oui parce que si
maman j'ai raté l'avion
bâtard ça fait drôle haïti mme hamouri
cette page en cours que je posais perdre
ou de gagner tu parles en quarts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous les jours à 18h40 il y aura ce
qu'on appelle les olympiades le jeu il
faut envoyer une balle entre les deux
bipèdes avec les langues de belle-mère
totalement mamie ledentu un coup d'arrêt
terriblement mamie le dentier pouf
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est mieux on m'a dit bon ami
c'est dit
[Applaudissements]
c'est sur le maire si je commençais
plein air mais ben là c'est plus est la
leur
[Applaudissements]
qu importe quel public
thomas do
[Musique]
l'étendard
m
les tendances
[Applaudissements]
moi je vous dis on fait cinq balles à
120 agents mais je vais une des balles
réelles du hashtag balle sur twitter
j'offre tout de suite le wali j'offrirai
si je le mets si je mets une des balles
j'offre mon salaire du jour nasa à un
téléspectateur mais vous changer sa vie
mathieu
[Applaudissements]
je mets ce gel dans le saladier une
personne sur twitter repartira avec mon
c'est à dire du jour ce sera la deuxième
[Applaudissements]
ça